[Music]
what was your reaction when you found
out that some people were calling re not
Peter
it was funny but it's also unfair you
know skies got a world against him from
the very start he's got to go against
people saying not Peter he's got people
saying that the show is maybe pushing
the idea of engagement too much and then
he had his own kind of trials of an
ex-girlfriend in his life saying
something so he was really trying to get
up a mount to get the show started and
he really just does seem like a nice guy
who is looking for love and this was his
opportunity to do it you know if you're
asked to be the bachelor and you're
single and you're you're looking for
love why not so I felt kind of bad for
him have you guys spoken at all I
haven't no never spoken to him what are
you watching the show I watched the
first two episodes I think that Ari
seems like a very genuine kind person
he's quiet he's kind of reserved in
parts of the the show at least from what
you see et caught up with former
bachelorettes star Peter Krause a New
York City on Tuesday while promoting his
new social networking app highs these
days it seems the personal trainer is
focused on his business not the bachelor
Mike Weiss tweeted you were going to be
on winter games yep what happened with
that Mike place has said a lot of things
through his Twitter over time that are
maybe pushing a little bit or misleading
in certain ways and I think it's just
him trying to get to know the audience
figure out what he personally wants to
do with the show and he used my name a
couple of times but I don't think I
actually meant anything they didn't
choose me to be on the Winter Games was
it offered to you it was offered at one
point like again kind of like the
bachelor thing like is this something
that you'd be interested in and I
actually said yeah if I'd be interested
in winter games it sounds like fun I'm
glad I didn't get chosen because I'm
terrible at winter sports I mean like
brutally brutally terrible
[Music]
you
[Music]